on any given day a substantial
proportion of the business news is about
strategy beyond markets that makes it
timely topical interesting and engaging
[Music]
this program is about interactions with
the public it's about interactions with
government it's about interactions with
legal and regulatory authorities all of
which can have a profound effect on a
firm's profitability in the marketplace
it's
evidence-based deep structural thinking
that literally does not exist anywhere
else at any other school
that's what's really exciting about it
the program is intended to equip today's
leaders and tomorrow's future leaders
with tools that they can implement on
the day they return to their
organization
new ideas new tools different ways of
thinking and maybe employing new tactics
broader strategies in the
non-market-oriented
realm but more importantly than that i'm
developing a confidence around the
importance of these sorts of things
you can't sort of come up with your
business plan and then come up with your
plan for dealing with governments and
the public you need to think of those
two things at the same time it just
creates a broadening of our traditional
points of view that we otherwise
wouldn't have had how an organization
handles a crisis can have short-term and
long-term impact on an organization's
reputation and ability to participate in
the marketplace
and if you can do a better job dealing
with those things than your competitors
do that's really a powerful foundation
for success in the marketplace i feel
more prepared and effective as a return
to google to advance policy issues on
the ground
as i know what to say when to say and
how to say it
imagine you're a deep-sea diver diving
in the dark and someone comes along and
offers you an oxygen tank a flashlight
and a grid map of the bottom of the
ocean you liked diving but now you have
an extraordinary opportunity to think
about the world and understand where you
are and what your choices are in a very
different way
participants in the program will walk
away with a set of concrete tools for
how to interact and how to strategically
understand what's going on with interest
groups with activists with governments
and with courts and regulatory
authorities ways of conceptualizing what
those other folks are doing and how to
deal with them strategically
[Music]